well as some of you may recall there was
a little warehouse fire some years ago
where we'd stored quite a lot of stuff
and that kind of taught us to aji
duplicate and separate which in the
digital age is much easier now and it
also said to us actually it's worth
Kagan are Christian so we now have a
full-time archivist he's came sort of
through the BFI was well trained at
Union in film archiving so this sort of
work we've been doing how to preserve
films he's got archivist written all the
way through him which is fantastic and
his task and she start of a shoot is to
talk to the producers and say what are
you doing I want that back back don't
chuck it away you don't need to keep
everything but you want to keep one of
everything so you'll you'll will keep
say all the store bought some one
particular sequence and certain models
you haven't got space to keep everything
what's happened of late which has been
great is that we've had a demand for
exhibitions and so all that stuff which
you have saved has gone into exhibitions
gets remounted and people love looking
at it it's fantastic can you see the
sets in particular the beautiful works
of art mean that they're like in the
ultimate doll's house in many ways
beautiful things so that's the process
now obviously I've a lot of stills in
there which we actually into force it
cracked or quite extensively actually
and it's just great have that all in one
place and we have a warehouse which is
full of all the physical stuff which we
know we we add to we add to and take
away at the same time as it were but it
from our point of view it's really quite
important because particularly bigger
films there's a great afterlife in
exhibitions and touring shows and things
and actually we've says we recycled them
we were using bits of sets from the
Pirates filming l'shana sheep movie see
if you can spot them but as you would do
you know in any major studio you've got
all those props and things you don't
want to just check them away you do want
to get more value out of them so it's
quite it's quite it's quite a big thing
actually it's great having a full-time
archivist taking care that it kind of
gives you a lot of kind of confidence
that you know you're going to keep you
right staff and actually you can find
stuff when you want it that's the other
great fears where is that photograph
it's here from
I can't so it is it's not olding shoe
boxes under the bed somewhere